i started eating hot cheeses with
chopsticks why yeah it's a lot cleaner
and you don't have cheeto today we're
going to be trying the internet's
favorite hot cheeto combinations i was
one of those people that ate hot cheetos
at 7am in the morning and i'm not
ashamed you were the hot cheeto girl
that would walk in the class for sure
and you can hear you in the back of the
classic
let's go hot cheetos
all right he has the hot cheetos
oh
okay
he's crunching them
bread
wow this is like garnish something
really nice on top oh oh yeah mango
arizona drop the arizona on top
some whipped cream we got some sour sour
cream
wait where do you put the the sour cream
i don't know to be honest
oh
okay
he's drinking the arizona then he's
gonna take a mouthful of sour cream oh
okay okay yeah let's do it cheers
[Music]
oh my gosh it's so good
how many calories are in this
too many oil water
here i'll give you my big oh
it's almost like it's too thick you have
to like chew a lot
i like thick things in my
oh
i'm just kidding it wasn't
and it's an outfit
it's like a really thick hot cheeto i
like it i like it a lot it's messy
he's finishing it i saw spice king
trying these today so i tasted right
avocado with a crushed up flaming hot
lemon cheetos it's a whole avocado
i don't know if i can do that i mean
oh my god
absolutely
i don't believe her i don't believe her
either i don't believe her because she
was like
good
i am scared for my bowel systems later
on tonight because this is going to be
spicy
diarrhea i don't know
tmi but
definitely going to be burning on the
toilet but you know it's fine yeah
[Music]
all right this is not easy to eat so
let's try this mouthful
[Music]
it's bomb i think the only reason i'm
tripping is because i put a lot of lime
lemon juice and a lot of tajin
so it's it's hitting me but it's really
good i think it needs more of this is
this vegan
now i consider the crushed bugs to make
the red oh no
not the books does this speaking of why
are they red oh my god yeah now that i
add the lemon no jade add more of this
no i have a lot of lemon mine's just
kind of like
it's still raining over there the whole
thing fell look it's a whole
river i want to know who was just in
their kitchen like i don't have no food
in the refrigerator all i have is
avocados hot cheetos lemon juice and
some tahini
person was like no all these go together
why has no one put these together before
no i say this person was high as heck
and this is like a high snack
it's good it hurts but it's good
i'm intrigued so i feel hurt i feel hurt
i feel her i have my honey bun here and
my cheetos here oh honey i'm gonna go
ahead and crush our most cheetos now i
have my crushed up cheetos so i'm gonna
go ahead and just oh
yes a dip you dip that is not a dip
that's a dip that is not a dip it's like
a whatever that sound is she she did not
do this yes she did you're thinking of
vegemite all right that's what you're
thinking of snoring she went like this
now we're gonna dip okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah and just
mix it a little bit that's what it looks
like and it kind of looks like
strawberry shortcake on camera wow it
does
i don't know
[Music]
no it tasted like soap or something like
i got soap in my mouth i see where
they're going with it i see the vision
but it just me it made me think of soap
if i'm thinking of soap it's not good
you know what i started doing i started
eating hot cheese with chopsticks
but i also think that like
why yeah it's a lot cleaner and you
don't have cheeto fingers i love cheeto
fingers that's the best part oh he likes
it it's gone
alex likes soap
we did a lot of things with cheetos that
people don't usually do but i might even
put this on like steak next time
oh
what's the winner the winner is
[Music]
avocados and hot cheetos and tahini and
mine get that and try it it is really
good tik tok was not lying on that
[Music]